فري فري بال فري فري فري فري فري فري
فري بال فري فري فري فري جي فري فري
com.gtinertiner
ز
[موسيقى]
تجمعنا لأننا نواصل الوقوف من أجل
السلام والعدالة صوتنا
تريد رفع وأنا أتساءل كيف
لا يزال يتعين تنظيم العديد من المسيرات والعروض التوضيحية
يكون ضروريا مثل العديد من الأبرياء
لا يزال يتعين على الأطفال أن يموتوا من أجلهم
حكومة الإنسانية جمعاء
عيون مفتوحة ومعاناة الناس
توقف الشعب الفلسطيني
لا يعاني لأكثر من شهرين
لكننا هنا منذ أكثر من 75 عامًا
استنفدت من الصور الوحشية و
فيديوهات ننشرها يوميا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
شاهد الصحفيين الفلسطينيين
يخاطرون بحياتهم فقط من أجلنا جميعًا
لإظهار الحقيقة نحن مرهقون
متعبين وضعفاء رغم أننا كذلك
هنا في ألمانيا حيث ليس لدينا أي شيء
علينا أن نخاف من ذلك بين عشية وضحاها
قنبلة
يلتقي